[Música]
si no hay políticas más ambiciosas el
consumo de plástico en el mundo se puede
hasta triplicar para 2060 la ocde lanzó
esta advertencia en 2022 Pero ha
cambiado el panorama desde entonces por
un lado 180 países intentan pactar el
que sería el primer tratado legalmente
vinculante para ponerle fin a la
contaminación por plásticos y en la
última ronda de negociación que se
realizó en París hubo avances pues
acordaron escribir el primer borrador
del pacto pero de otro lado la realidad
muestra que solo el 9% del plástico que
se produce se recicla según la octe y el
resto termina en vertederos se quema o
terminan por ejemplo en los océanos hoy
en el debate discutimos que hace falta
para frenar esta contaminación a
propósito del Día Mundial del medio
ambiente que se conmemora el 5 de junio
para analizar el tema hoy nos acompaña
desde quito María Inés rivadeneira
oficial de políticas de WWF Ecuador y
coordinadora de políticas para WWF
América Latina y el Caribe y en Ginebra
Suiza está Andrés del Castillo abogado
senior del centro para el derecho
internacional ambiental no olviden
ustedes nuestros televidentes que
también hacen parte de este debate puede
dejar sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram nos encuentran como
arroba France 24 raya al piso es y
pueden comentar con la etiqueta numeral
el debate f-24 a mí me encuentran como
arroba María claguire todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
también disponibles en Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Ahora sí quiero darle la bienvenida a
nuestros invitados Empezando por ustedes
de María Inés Gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros empecemos por dar un panorama
general de Qué se necesita para poder
reducir la contaminación por plásticos
en el mundo
Muchas gracias por la invitación que
gusto también compartir este espacio con
mi colega
esta pregunta quisiera empezar señalando
que pese a los esfuerzos que se han
hecho en los últimos años en algunos
países por ejemplo en América Latina
casi un un total de veinte países
cuentan con políticas de algún tipo
relacionada con el uso del plástico
siguen siguen siendo como iniciativas
aisladas que no permiten avanzar en una
regulaciones más robustas y ambiciosas a
Asia de tener definitivamente esta
contaminación por plásticos como ya has
mencionado tú el hecho de que cada vez
estén ingresando en el ambiente
diferentes tipos de plásticos hace que
estemos enfrentando un problema de salud
para la humanidad pero también para el
ambiente y es por eso que es importante
avanzar en un tratado que sea vinculante
pero también en regulaciones que sean
estrictas sobre la producción y el
consumo Es decir tanto necesitamos de
políticas públicas que sean de nivel
global vinculantes como de políticas
nacionales pero también necesitamos
cambiar el comportamiento sobre la
producción y el consumo avanzar hacia un
consumo responsable y hasta reglas
claras sobre la producción especialmente
de aquellos plásticos que son altamente
contaminantes y riesgosos para la salud
usted habla de dos componentes vitales
en toda esta discusión y es por un lado
la producción de plástico y por el otro
lado el consumo abordemos primero la
producción Andrés gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en el debate Cuál es
el panorama que usted nos da sobre la
cantidad de toneladas que se producen de
plástico en el mundo Cada año
Sí muchas gracias María Clara a ti al
equipo de producción y a la audiencia
desde acá desde Ginebra Suiza Les mando
un saludo y estamos muy agradecidos por
la invitación
para la celebración también del día
internacional del medio ambiente Creo
que este este debate es más que adecuado
y sobre tu pregunta de la producción
obviamente las los datos que que nos
ofreces según la sede La amenaza de
triplicar la la oferta de plástico de
aquí a 2050 o 2060 es inminente se está
poniendo en práctica ya existen muchos y
muchas inversiones yendo en esta
dirección de
abarcar la industria petroquímica si no
se hace nada no habrá ningún sistema de
gestión de desechos que pueda controlar
eso Y esto no quiere decir que si lo que
se quiere es acabar con el plástico pero
si quiere controlar una sustancia que
está fuera de control y sabemos que es
una entre sustancias más producidas en
el mundo y necesitamos una especie de
control saber qué plásticos van para el
consumo Y qué plásticos son para uso
Industrial hoy en día no tenemos ningún
ninguna frontera y los plásticos se
mueven de un lado para otro desde el
plástico que se utiliza para un casco
para proteger a un trabajador de una
obra es el mismo plástico ABS que se
utiliza para los para hacer los los
Legos que se ponen los niños en la boca
entonces necesitamos una especie de
control no solamente en la cantidad de
producción pero también en los usos y
las aplicaciones como decía María antes
y precisamente en estos usos hay
diferente clase de plásticos y quiero
que le podamos explicar a nuestra
audiencia la diferencia Y qué es lo que
se está discutiendo en el tratado María
Inés porque por ejemplo no es lo mismo
hablar de Pet que es el plástico que se
utiliza sobre todo en las botellas
plásticas de agua por nombrar algo y
fácilmente reciclable a otros como el
polietileno de alta densidad de que lo
encontramos por ejemplo en los envases
de los productos de aseo o el
polietileno de baja densidad que es el
de las bolsas plásticas Y tenemos otros
como los por ejemplo las famosas tetra
pack que son estas cajas de leche que
tienen diferentes componentes no solo
plásticos sino también por ejemplo
cartón etcétera que hace que su
reciclaje sea muy difícil por no decir
imposible cómo explicarle a la audiencia
Cuál es la dificultad de reciclar el
plástico
Muchas gracias por eso
esta pregunta es importantísima sobre
todo para generar conciencia en el
consumo sabemos que en la producción se
están utilizando plástico para
diferentes aplicaciones se los utiliza
para el sector Automotriz se utiliza
para la fabricación de textiles también
para la agricultura y otros muchos usos
de la vida cotidiana estamos
acostumbrados a consumir diferentes
tipos de plásticos los más peligrosos de
un informe de wwwf reciente nos señala
que es posible identificar aquellos que
son peligrosos que son sustancias
químicas peligrosas y aquellas que
pueden tener otro tipo de tratamiento es
importante justo en esta en este tipo de
conversaciones internacionales para
llegar a acuerdos globales que sean
rigurosos que sean muy responsables el
avanzar hacia la prohibición de estos
polímetros como tú mencionabas de estos
productos plásticos de alto riesgo de
que además están en su gran mayoría
enfocados al un uso o un uso de tiempo
muy corto no la mayoría de estos del 50%
están enfocados en empaques para
diferentes tipos de productos sabemos
que hay alternativas pero sobre todo hay
que distinguir de aquellos que hay que
retirar del mercado porque tiene
representan un riesgo súper alto para la
salud humana pero también para las
especies por ejemplo hay datos
interesantísimos que nos dicen que el
70% de las especies de vida Silvestre se
ven afectadas por los plásticos que
terminan en los océanos o que en general
circulan por el ambiente Entonces esta
distinción creo que es la más importante
para la ciudadanía saber que la mayoría
de plásticos que se utilizan en empaques
que son desechables que son desechables
de muy poco de corto alcance no que se
pueden usar una vez o que se usan por
muy corto tiempo son los más peligrosos
ustedes dos coinciden en que hay clases
de plásticos que se pueden catalogar
como sustancias químicas peligrosas
Andrés qué clase de plástico son estos y
cuáles son los que representan más
riesgo para la salud humana y para la
salud de los ecosistemas
Sí ya cuando hablamos de plástico como
material entendemos que aunque Existen
tres definiciones jurídicamente
vinculantes podemos decir resumir que
son sustancias químicas muy complejas de
definir y son muchas muchas sustancias
un estudio de la comisión europea decía
que en el mercado existen
aproximadamente 200.000 polímeros sí de
los cuales hay 13 mil sustancias
químicas que se utilizan en la
producción de plásticos según un informe
de El penuma que se hizo de público hace
dos semanas y en el informe se dijo que
de esos 13.000 de esos 13.000 sustancias
químicas no se tienen datos de
aproximadamente 6.200 y de la otra mitad
de lo que se tiene información sabemos
que 3.200 sustancias son de alta
preocupación para la comunidad
científica por qué Porque son sustancias
que pueden tener con a nivel de
toxicología a nivel del sobrino del
sistema endocrino o a nivel de de la
bioacumulación de en este caso hablamos
de diferentes familias o grupos de
familias como los pifás o los bisfenoles
que se conocen también como
bpa es una clase de bisfenol pero es una
familia también bps puede ser Igualmente
tóxico Entonces estamos hablando de
muchos muchos muchos
sustancias químicas que se utilizan en
la producción de plásticos y está
complejidad del material por la cantidad
de sustancias que se utiliza también es
un es un problema no solamente para el
medio ambiente sino también para la
biota y para la salud humana y lo que se
quiere llegar con este tratado de
plástico es un poco a través de la
simplificación química mirar cómo se
agrupan estas sustancias y se clasifican
como sustancias de alta preocupación a
nivel grupal y no una por una como se
viene haciendo a nivel de
a nivel mundial porque a nivel mundial
más o menos solo hay 128 sustancias o
130 que están reguladas a través de del
protocolo de Montreal o de la convención
de estocolmo Andrés es decir que el
resto de las 13.000
de plástico que pueden ser
potencialmente tóxicas siguen
produciéndose y consumiéndose en el
mundo
exactamente podríamos decir que a nivel
nacional existen aproximadamente 1000 de
esas sustancias que sí están controladas
por jurisdicciones nacionales o por
países pero a nivel internacional solo
130 Entonces eso es lo que se busca con
este tratado un poco controlar las
sustancias y permitir aquellas que que
demuestran que los datos son
suficientemente confiables para entrar
en el mercado Bueno pero entonces Quiero
preguntarle a María Inés Qué se puede
hacer mientras llega al Tratado porque
apenas van dos de cinco rondas de
negociaciones que se espera se puedan
extender hasta el 2024 y en caso tal de
que pacten un acuerdo internacional
legalmente vinculante Sería más o menos
para el 2025 e incluso así en la segunda
ronda hubo acciones dilatorias como
debates sobre los mecanismos de
participación y prolongación en los
debates qué hacer mientras este pacto se
hace y qué pasó en esta reunión de París
esta pregunta voy a separarla como en
dos respuestas Entonces primero Como qué
podemos hacer mientras tanto creo que es
muy importante a medida que va avanzando
la ciencia ir identificando esta
información que como mencionaba mi
colega es muy compleja pero que puede
permitir identificar Cuáles son las
mejores políticas y regulaciones a nivel
nacional para reducir la producción de
aquellos contaminantes de aquellos
materiales riesgosos y también promover
el uso de aquellos que no se pueden
sacar del mercado el el reciclaje o el
reuso de ciertos materiales no entonces
creo que ir a la fase de regulación y
control de la producción es
importantísimo creo que también es
importante el rol que juega la
ciudadanía en tener mayor conciencia
sobre el consumo y sobre generar también
como algunas alternativas frente a este
este problema de contaminación tan grave
por otro lado lo que está sucediendo en
París
también mencionas hay varias series hay
varias rondas de negociación ahora
Estamos en la segunda ronda la siguiente
se va a celebrar en noviembre en Kenia y
estamos avanzando En cuáles van a ser
estos mínimos que van a permitir la
construcción de este tratado ahora se
tiene un primer borrador entre las
decisiones más importantes está
justamente el poder clasificar estos
materiales de riesgosos del generar
estas previsiones sobre estos polímeros
y productos de alto riesgo pero también
la reducción de la producción y consumo
que es algo que ya mencioné la promoción
de la reutilización y reciclaje la
gestión responsable de desechos y
plásticos algo que para WWF es súper
importante y que quisiera destacar es
que también se debe considerar en este
proceso una transición justa para a
aquellas personas que están involucradas
en todo el ciclo relacionado con el
plástico no Si estamos fomentando salir
de un forma de estas formas de
producción que están contaminando y que
están dañando el ambiente y la salud
humana también Es importante saber que
se deben crear alternativas para que
estas personas puedan incursionar en
otro mercado laboral con las capacidades
adecuadas tomando en cuenta que en todo
el circuito el plástico hay trabajos
formales e informales y en el sector
informal también se encuentra una
población bastante vulnerable como son
las recicladoras y recicladores de base
Entonces sí queremos avanzar pero creo
que se puede hacer una combinación
paralela de iniciativas a nivel nacional
mientras se avanza con el ámbito global
así este acuerdo vinculante sin embargo
en el ámbito global hay una gran disputa
o una gran dificultad y es la posición
de los países más productores de
plástico que generalmente suelen ser los
más industrializados y la posición de
los países en desarrollo de hecho de los
180 países que están sentados en estas
rondas de negociaciones para el tratado
de plásticos 135 es decir faltan 45 más
135 Proponen reglas que sean vinculantes
de manera equitativa para todos los
países Andrés quienes están en
desacuerdo con esto y por qué se oponen
Sí yo creo que hay un grupo que está
está de acuerdo en tener medidas
vinculantes hay otro grupo que se opone
y hay otro grupo que está todavía
indeciso en en materia de no tener una
posición tan Clara Pero los que los que
se oponen son países en su mayoría
productores de de hidrocarburos que ven
en el plástico la salida hacia lo que
vemos una reducción de la demanda de
hidrocarburos para la gasolina en los
próximos en el próximo decenio el como
Plan B para salvar un poco la industria
petroquímica los plásticos la salida no
el salvavidas entonces vemos países como
saudí Arabia que se posiciona muy fuerte
contra cualquier medida de control vemos
también países como los brics
exceptuando a África del sur no Brasil
Rusia India y China se posicionaron muy
fuerte al comienzo
con un poco excusas o argumentos de
materia procedimental no de que Cuáles
son las reglas de juego y si se debe
utilizar el consenso o si se debe
utilizar la posibilidad del voto no
entonces ahí duramos más o menos dos
días y medio de discusión solamente
cuando estos países volvieron a abrir
estas reglas de procedimiento que se
habían discutido un año antes en en
dacar y más o menos condicionaron la
posibilidad de que se pudiera votar en
esta Ronda de negociación lo que es una
Primicia en temas de negociaciones
Internacionales y vemos que en otros
acuerdos
la no posibilidad de votar ha sido un
impedimento para llegar a soluciones más
de fondos Y estos lo doy como ejemplo en
el en el tema del acuerdo de París y la
convención marco de cambio climático en
la regla de Procedimientos sobre
posibilidad de Voto está todavía entre
paréntesis por eso es que
no se puede votar y todo se tiene que
usar bajo consenso y el consenso es muy
bueno pero cuando se usa mal puede
llegar a llamarse un veto entonces
exactamente Es más legítimo pero es
mucho más difícil de lograr cuando
estamos hablando de países que dependen
altamente en en la renta petrolera o de
gas O de o de carbón usted Menciona un
punto clave y es la relación de las
petroleras y de las Industrias y los
países petroleros con los plásticos
María Inés qué hay detrás Cómo se
vinculan estas dos empresas sobre todo
con algo que se llaman los plásticos
vírgenes Cuál es la diferencia frente a
los reciclados
bueno volvemos otra vez al tema químico
y tiene que ver con Cuáles son esas
sustancias que se están utilizando para
el desarrollo de ciertos plásticos no
entonces hay plásticos que tienen un
origen fósil es decir que se están
utilizando químicos para mejorar sus
aplicaciones
y que tienen que ver con la vida útil o
con el uso que se va a dar no Entonces
en ese sentido hay una hay una relación
directa sobre el origen de esos de esos
químicos del origen de estas sustancias
que permiten este mejoramiento del uso
del plástico sin embargo También es
importante señalar que en esta en este
espacio de negociación internacional
Pese que siempre tiene sus complejidades
y Pese a que se ve como un avance más
lento es un espacio democrático donde
pueden los países independientemente de
su origen de su actividad de su De dónde
viene como su economía básica pueden
participar y pueden tener voz y por
ejemplo para bueno para wf es súper
importante destacar esto no destacar que
es importante el multilateralismo que es
importante contar con Estos espacios de
discusión y también que existen buenas
noticias por ejemplo con coaliciones
como la coalición de alta ambición donde
ya participan cerca de cincuenta
gobiernos y que ellos están haciendo
declaraciones para aumentar la ambición
y para promover esta esta fin de
plásticos entonces creo que también hay
que destacar y es importante poner en
contexto como varias cosas que están
pasando al mismo tiempo y yo quiero
contrastar eso positivo que usted está
diciendo de estas alianzas
internacionales que cada vez se
fortalecen más para acabar con la
contaminación por plásticos pero de otro
lado tenemos por ejemplo el manejo de
los residuos plásticos hace algunos años
concretamente en 2017 China prohibió la
importación y la compra de residuos a
otros países dentro de ellos varios
tipos de plástico lo cual generó un caos
mundial Por decirlo así porque china
hasta el 2016 recibía el 56% de los
residuos tóxicos de otros países y esto
hizo que países como Estados Unidos
Canadá o incluso miembros de la Unión
Europea comenzaran a enviar sus plástico
la basura de plástico los residuos a
otros países vecinos como Vietnam o
Tailandia luego en 2019 estos países
comenzaron a oponerse a recibir esos
plásticos hoy por hoy dónde están estos
residuos Y qué está pasando con los
países más productores de plástico a
donde están tirando su basura por
decirlo así Andrés
Sí claro este es el lado uno de los
lados oscuros de
de lo que llamamos el ciclo de vida de
plásticos que es la parte corriente
abajo relacionada con con la basura
plástica y como bien nos mencionabas
María Clara en 2018 esta ley que se
llamaba la ley de espada nacional china
cambia un poco las reglas de juego del
mundo de un lado
hizo más visible esta problemática la
cual la mayoría de la población no tenía
ni idea y lo segundo aceleró las
acciones a nivel internacional Entonces
esto hizo que en el 2018 a 2019 se
adoptará en un tiempo récord una
enmienda a uno de los convenios que
controla el movimiento transfronterizo
de desechos tóxicos y se incluyeran los
plásticos ahí salvo algunas excepciones
con algunas salvaguardias que se le dan
a los países para que ellos den su
consentimiento antes de que lleguen
productos o desechos plásticos
importados a su país no entonces esos
son ciertas salvaguardias que los países
tienen para poder decir No no quiero que
vengan residuos y
estas enmiendas ya entran en vigor y son
legalmente vinculantes a nivel
internacional para todos los países casi
todos los países del Mundo 183 países
menos Estados Unidos pero Estados Unidos
al no ser parte también tiene tiene
algunos efectos que se que se ven frente
a
la posibilidad de estos países de no
aceptar estos desechos provenientes de
Estados Unidos pero hay informes que nos
dicen que América Latina se está
convirtiendo en el basurero de Estados
Unidos entonces vemos un aumento en la
importación de productos plásticos de
basura plástica en México y en varios
países como Colombia Ecuador Perú y
hasta Brasil hemos encontrado evidencia
de esos del lado de Estados Unidos pero
también del lado de Europa hacia Turquía
que es un gran receptor y los países
como mencionabas del sudeste asiático
que es continúa aún recibiendo grandes
cantidades y toneladas de plástico ya
sea porque de manera legal o de manera
ilegal cuando se escribe en la en la
declaración de exportación que no es
plástico si no se escribe que es papel
para reciclaje es muy difícil a veces de
controlar para los controladores de
Puerto que está verdaderamente
containers usted nos explica que América
Latina se está convirtiendo en el
basurero de los plásticos que produce
Estados Unidos María Inés Cuáles son las
consecuencias que está viendo la región
a causa de esto
Bueno Este es un problema es un problema
gravísimo o sea nosotros podemos
observar por ejemplo que América Latina
en general es la región con un con la
menor tasa de reciclaje en el mundo
varía por países pero en general es
bastante complicado en el país dice el
Vid en su último estudio al respecto que
llegan a los océanos unos cuatro
millones de toneladas de plástico al año
lo que significa una tercera parte de la
estimación global que es de un total de
11 millones al año hay falta de datos
unificados creo que ese es uno de los
problemas que enfrentamos en la región
definitivamente necesitamos información
para poder contrastarle y tomar mejores
decisiones pero también se necesita
indiscutiblemente decisiones políticas
se necesita una mejor planificación
sobre la gestión en general del
territorio sobre la gestión de residuos
se necesita como establecer unas reglas
en cuanto a la relación con muchos
países contra el como mencionaba Andrés
con el inglés o no de estos de estos
plásticos a nuestros países
y depende mucho de la voluntad política
y para eso se necesita información que
permita tomar decisiones de manera
correcta pero estamos viendo por lo
menos en América Latina que se están
Tomando estas acciones políticas para
reducir la contaminación por plástico
Marianas
Mira es interesante porque sí se observa
que hay algunas decisiones una depende
mucho de los países Sí se ve un avance
en términos de tomar decisiones pero no
necesariamente que están orientadas a
corregir como el ciclo completo del
plástico Qué es lo recomendable lo
recomendable es que se
empiece la mano de
cómo se gestiona el territorio Cómo se
estamos teniendo fallas en la conexión
con nuestra invitada María Inés
rivadeneira le pasó entonces la pregunta
a usted Andrés ya no solo en América
Latina sino si estamos viendo una
voluntad política determinada a frenar
la contaminación por plásticos o todavía
falta mucho camino por recorrer En ese
sentido
Sí claro que existe voluntad y desde
América Latina hemos observado desde
antes del comienzo de las negociaciones
liderazgo de por la parte de diferentes
países Ecuador Perú y chile podríamos
decir que son los líderes la materia no
no falta agregar que el presidente de
este comité intergubernamental de
negociación que es como se conoce el
comité donde se negocia el tratado ahora
es el embajador Gustavo mesa cuadra que
ha hecho un trabajo fenomenal y lo
seguirá para las últimas tres rondas de
negociación el viceministro de Ecuador
Luis vallas también vemos desde Costa
Rica un liderazgo como siempre en temas
ambientales Colombia se ha sumado al
tema lo que vimos en la última en la
última negociación fue un poco el cambio
el viraje de un Brasil y un y una
Argentina más precavidos y Guatemala y
Cuba y Venezuela también un poco más
precavidos y alineándose un poco con
estos países querían un poco
distanciarse de la negociación de fondo
y seguir en estas negociaciones
procedimentales pero si vemos una visión
en América Latina ahora en el mundo
también existe esta ambición lo que pasa
es que muchas veces hablamos lenguajes
diferentes inclusive es en la ONU no Qué
se entiende por contaminación
proplásticos para uno sería solamente
los detritos en el medio ambiente que
causan daños para otros es todas las
emisiones y los riesgos del plástico
desde su producción consumo uso desecho
y fugas no entonces también depende Y
esto es lo que se está intentando
negociar y lo que se está intentando
llegar a un acuerdo cuál es el alcance
de este tratado que se debe descubrir
pero sí existe voluntad porque
a nivel de cambio climático también hay
un vínculo muy fuerte y sabemos que la
gente climática sigue en el top de la
agenda multilateral y sabemos que los
plásticos Como dijo hoy en día en el
mensaje del día internacional del medio
ambiente el secretario general de
Naciones Unidas los plásticos son
energías fósiles de otra forma y esto
entre más plástico producimos más
hidrocarburos quemamos y más exacerbamos
la crisis climática no Entonces estos
mensajes que vienen de lo alto también
demuestran la ambición O como usted
ahora el plástico es el Plan B de las
petroleras y en ese sentido la ocde
afirma que el plástico es responsable
por lo menos en 2019 del 3,4% de los
gases de efecto invernadero que se
produjeron en todo el mundo es una
cantidad enorme comparada con el
petróleo o el gas sin embargo no es
mayor por supuesto a estos combustibles
fósiles al menos de manera directa María
Inés teniendo en cuenta la conexión de
la que nos habla Andrés entre la
producción de plástico y la
contaminación y el calentamiento global
y la crisis climática qué tanto impacto
pueden tener países como los
latinoamericanos sabiendo que no son tan
productores de plástico versus una china
un Estados Unidos una Unión Europea es
decir en la balanza final del impacto
del plástico en la crisis climática
realmente suficiente que los países del
sur pacten acuerdos para frenar la
contaminación o esto se necesita de
todos los países
varios elementos en este sentido O sea
primero en el marco el cambio climático
uno de los sectores de mitigación es el
de residuos Entonces definitivamente sí
se puede aportar con la reducción de los
gases que se emiten en vertederos de
basura por ejemplo eso es importante
señalar sin embargo también hay que
decir que América Latina emite
aproximadamente el ocho por ciento de
gases de efecto de invernadero globales
no entonces hay algo en materia de
cambio climático que se llama
responsabilidades comunes pero
diferenciadas que justamente buscan
Resaltar esto que tú mencionas que es
decir los países que más producen más
responsabilidad también deben tener a
nivel internacional sobre las
consecuencias de esta producción y
países o regiones como las nuestras que
son más vulnerables a los efectos
negativos del cambio climático necesitan
no solamente creación de capacidades y
recursos sino también asumir compromisos
pero diferenciados de acuerdo a sus
condiciones nacionales
Ahora sí es importante sumarse a estas
iniciativas y encontrar Cuáles son esos
vínculos entre los diferentes acuerdos
internacionales y aquí llamaría incluso
a la mesa también la convención de
diversidad biológica por el hecho de
cuánto en daño causa esta contaminación
por plásticos a la a la salud en general
de la naturaleza de los bosques del agua
de los océanos y también de las personas
entonces sí es importante encontrar esos
vínculos entre las diferentes
convenciones internacionales y ver de
qué manera el atacar este problema que
es una crisis global y que nos llama
tomar acciones urgentes globales también
puede aportar a los objetivos comunes de
otras Cumbres internacionales y
precisamente a propósito de que usted
habla de las convenciones quiero
recordarle a nuestra audiencia que según
la ONU y según la ciencia Existen tres
crisis que enfrenta el planeta
actualmente la primera es la crisis del
cambio climático la segunda es crisis
por la pérdida de biodiversidad y la
tercera es precisamente por
contaminación donde el plástico no es el
único factor pero es un factor
determinante y frente a la primera
crisis la climática existe un convenio
internacional vinculante que es el
acuerdo de París para la segunda la
pérdida de biodiversidad también existe
un acuerdo vinculante que es el convenio
de diversidad biológica que mencionó
María Inés y para la contaminación aún
no existe un tratado legalmente
vinculante que reúne y que obliga a
todos los países a respetarlo Andrés Qué
tan lejos estamos de lograrlo
especialmente en materia de plásticos
yo creo que estamos un paso más adelante
después de la decisión que se tomó en la
segunda Ronda de negociación en París de
darle el el la posibilidad la potestad
al presidente de la del comité
gubernamental de negociaciones de
escribir el borrador cero que es como se
conoce Este primer borrador donde los
estados pasan de una etapa de discutir
Cuáles son las soluciones a negociar
directamente sobre un texto Entonces
esta reunión que tendrá lugar en nairobi
que es la tercera Ronda de negociaciones
en noviembre será una reunión pivote
donde ya los estados empezarán a
negociar y Esperamos que de aquí a 2025
se tenga ya la posibilidad de hacer una
conferencia diplomática que es como se
cierran las convenciones normalmente
para la adopción para que se adopte por
la mayoría de Estados estamos muy
cercanos y también hay que hay que hay
que ser positivos desde América Latina
decir que existen reemplazos y en
América Latina es muy bueno en servicios
de reparación por ejemplo en
alternativas y sustitutos a los
plásticos y hay mucho potencialidad en
la parte de de lo que se puede generar y
contribuir desde América Latina Ya se
está haciendo bueno Y para ir cerrando
nuestro debate hemos discutido hasta
ahora el papel de las Industrias
productoras de los gobiernos Al momento
de determinar políticas y finalmente
quiero hablarles y preguntarles del
papel del consumidor si bien no debemos
trasladar toda la responsabilidad de la
contaminación por plástico a los
consumidores ustedes qué pueden
recomendarle a las personas en sus casas
que pueden hacer para disminuir la
contaminación por plástico Andrés y esta
ya sería la idea de conclusión
lo primero para que no se contaminen sus
propios cuerpos es no calentar ningún
plástico a más de 65 grados centígrados
porque es a cualquier plástico comienza
a emitir o a desprender sus aditivos
cuando se calientan eso es lo primero lo
otro no utilizar ollas que estén
recubiertas con teflón porque esto está
producido con pifaf y de resto e
intentar ir hacia alternativas y
sustitutos según sus posibilidades
sabiendo que necesitamos un cambio más
sistémicos donde haya opciones que se
han abordables y que el consumidor
también pueda
pueda comprarlas
Cuál es su conclusión al respecto
sistema que es insostenible social y
ambientalmente y es el de producir usar
y desechar creo que podemos llamar a un
ejercicio de transformación que nos
permita a través del cambio de
comportamiento primero en dejar de
producir aquello que es altamente
contaminante que es dañino para la salud
como decíamos de las personas y de la
naturaleza pero también llamarnos a
tener como otro tipo de comportamientos
y Buscar cuáles son esos otros
materiales que desde la desde los mismos
procesos biológicos podemos utilizar
como empaques que pueden evitar Esto del
un solo uso de uso de corto tiempo creo
que hay muchas alternativas y con mucha
alegría podemos ver también que hay cada
vez más personas que se están sumando a
esta conciencia de ver la cadena de
valor y no solamente uno de los
elementos del problema o de esta crisis
global de plásticos Bueno pues muchas
gracias a María Inés rivadeneira oficial
senior de políticas de WWF Ecuador y
también Andrés del Castillo abogado
senior de el centro para el derecho
internacional ambiental Gracias por
estar con nosotros en el debate y
gracias a ustedes nuestra audiencia por
elegir a France 24 la producción de este
programa estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando
Montes y la producción de los invitados
con Tania Herrera ustedes sigan con
nosotros porque tenemos más información
internacional
[Música]